(audience cheers and applauds)
- Have y'all, have y'all ever met before?
- No.
- No, we haven't. I'm
so excited to meet you.
- Me as well.
- It's so nice to meet you.
- I'm gonna, I'm gonna say
this is probably the shortest panel
that we have ever existed with, with me.
- I love this. Now how tall
are you? How tall are you?
- I'm 5'3 and a 1/2.
- 5'3 and a 1/2.
- I'm 5'2.
- Man, you guys are my goal heights.
- Wait, how tall are you?
- Wow. I'm 4'11 on a good day.
- Okay.
- I never quite hit 5 feet.
- I'm telling you it's, yeah.
I've never, all of a sudden you walked in,
I was like, I don't know if this is,
this is us right now.
(panel laughs)
- Well, Melissa, everyone loved you
on Big Bang Theory, obviously.
It's such a great show.
(crowd cheering)
- Thank you.
- What person doesn't love that show?
So you started out in comedy
doing impressions, right?
- I did, yeah.
I loved doing any sort of comedy as a kid
and I was like the kid on the playground
who didn't really understand recess.
Like, I didn't like I was like,
this seems exhausting,
(Kelly laughs)
just the running around.
So, I was like, how do I make
the most use of the time?
And I thought maybe I
could like make some coin.
I was always looking
for like, to save money
to get something at Claire's boutique.
So I was like, well maybe if I like,
say like, charge 25
cents for an impression,
I can make money.
But like,
if kids have pocket change
they're not gonna spend it on like
a Don Knotts impression
(audience laughs)
from a seven year-old.
- Yes.
- But I would do it anyway.
Occasionally, like, there were some takers
and then I, I was shut down eventually
'cause like my mom got a call
and they're like, "My
kid didn't buy milk today
because they said they
bought an Elf impression."
(everyone laughs)
- [Kelly] So Melissa, and
here you are as a kid.
(crowd cooing)
Look how cute you are.
Oh, on your, is this one of your shows?
- Yes. My brother and I would
do shows in our basement.
That was Little Shop of Horrors.
- [Kelly] Nice.
- We didn't really have a proper stage.
As you can see, that was a lawn chair
and there was always fear
that like your foot would fall through.
- Yes. It's one of the
plastic ones with the weave.
- Yeah, exactly. At any point
you could break an ankle.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Not the most appropriate
show for a six year-old.
- [Kelly] Probably not, but it's okay-
- Yeah.
- Most of it went over our heads.
- It's true. And to learn at a young age
that any point
you could get eaten by a man-eating plant.
- [Kelly] Totally.
- It builds character.
- Yeah.
It builds fear.
- [Melissa] Exactly.
- So, we didn't wanna leave Christina out.
So here's, here's Christina
around the same age.
(audience coos)
Look at you!
(Christina laughs)
- [Christina] My god.
- [Kelly] I mean, you
ribboned in everything, ma'am.
- I won. I won something. Yep.
- Yeah.
Do you, were you a swimmer?
My kids love swimming.
- I was.
- I kept trying to keep them in it.
- Yeah. I swam every
summer on a swim team.
- [Kelly] That's so cool.
- But not year round.
- Yeah, it's so good for
you. I keep trying to-
- That's probably why you broke five feet.
That's what I should have been doing.
(everyone laughs)
- Right.
- Just working, just working them out.
So wait, you're now in the new Night Court
and I love, we were just talking-
- Yeah.
- we love the original Night Court.
So is it similar, similar
to the original show?
- It is. It's very much a
continuation of the original.
We're calling it a new-boot
because it's not exactly a reboot.
It, it's very much has the
nostalgia of the original
and it's grounded in that history.
And we have the amazing
John Larroquette back.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Reprising his role as Dan Fielding.
- But we also have
this wonderful new cast
of characters around them.
So, people who aren't familiar
with the first incarnation,
they could come to it,
and needing no prior knowledge, and ...
So, yeah.
So, it's a new-boot, which we-
originally when we came up with that term,
it was a joke
and then we ended up liking it.
We were like, all right.
- [Kelly] I actually
thought it was awesome.
- Oh, cool.
- I heard y'all call it a new-boot
and I was like, how has
no one used that before?
- That's awesome.
- So, we are all mamas of two kids.
So how old are your kiddos?
- They're about three and five.
- Three and five?
- [Christina] Yeah.
- Okay, mine are six and eight.
That's not too far off.
- I've got 15 months
and an eight year-old.
- [Melissa] Oh wow.
- 15 months and an eight year-old.
So different.
You're carrying the-
you're carrying the bag again
(audience laughs)
with all the junk.
- Yeah. You got the-
- Like a Sherpa.
- Oh yeah. You should see my car.
(Kelly giggles)
(crowd cheering)
- So, we all have kiddos with similar ages
so we thought it might be nice
to take a moment for ourselves
and all the other rad mamas out there
by connecting over coffee
and answering a few mama
questions from our viewers.
This is A Rad Mama Moment.
(upbeat music)
Alright, thank you Marcel.
Give it up for Marcel. Giving us some-
(audience cheers)
I like it.
Oh, this is mine? Okay.
So wait.
Okay, I think this is yours
Melissa. Okay there we go.
- Oh, this is so nice.
- This is for you.
- Wow.
- Take it or don't,
but I love warm drinks.
- This is lovely.
- Yep.
- This is so nice.
- I'm like Elf when it
comes to tea and coffee.
(audience laughs)
So wait, so we have our refreshment.
So, now here's our first viewer question.
Are you ready?
- Let's do it.
- [Kelly] Ber ber ber.
- Yeah.
- Sherene from Chicago asks,
My kids are at very different stages,
but sometimes the older one
asks complicated questions
when the younger is around.
What are some harder questions
you've had to deal with
from your older kids in
front of the younger ones?
- Well, I'm outta this question
because Cleo, my 15 month old,
has no idea what's going on.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Christina] So there's
nothing to hide from her.
- [Kelly] Damn it. You got a pass. Okay.
- I'm out. Ladies?
- You know my question.
The things that that keep on bumping me
are the fact that
I feel like I should
have paid attention more
in elementary school.
Like if the teacher
had, would've said like,
learn this because at some
point your kid's gonna ask this.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- And you're not gonna
wanna look like a dummy.
- Yeah.
- Because now like they're,
the other day it was like,
how are clouds made?
I'm like, water droplets
turn into water vapor
(Kelly laughs)
and it goes into the sky.
And I'm like, I wish.
And then I'm like, Googling secretly,
and then reading it as if I know.
- I Google openly.
I'm like, let's find out.
(audience laughs)
And I'm like, I-
- [Melissa] That's good.
(audience claps)
- That's our whole thing is we like,
I go, let's see what,
you know, I know what it is,
but somebody else can explain
this better than I can.
- [Melissa] Totally.
- So I, I Google openly.
- It's a good-
- [Kelly] With no shame.
- That's great.
- Yeah, me and Freddie definitely
go online for things.
- Yes.
- My parents, they
wouldn't tell us anything.
We had to go check the encyclopedias.
- Yes.
- So, they were like,
what did we buy all
these encyclopedias for
if we're just gonna tell you everything?
So, I'm like, well, let's use Safari.
- Oh my God. Remember those encyclopedia?
- Oh yeah.
- We had a whole set.
We had to do our own research.
(audience claps)
- I, I never had those,
but I always wanted them.
My friends had, those were cool.
- They were useful.
- Here's the next one though.
It's from Lisa in Brooklyn and she says,
I have a five year-old
and am pregnant with my second.
How do you prepare your older child
for a new baby coming?
Ooh. How did you specifically do that?
Because they're pretty different ages.
- Well, Freddie has
always wanted a sibling
and begged me for one.
So, I was just like,
"You're getting a baby!"
(everyone laughs)
- Congratulations.
- You get a baby, you get a baby.
(audience titters)
And yeah, he, he was pretty fine about it.
He didn't really understand
how much attention the
baby would be needing.
And now he's sort of,
he'll watch us with her
and then he'll say,
"So, when I was a baby,
did I get this much attention?"
And I'm like, yes, you're alive. Right?
(everyone laughs)
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah. You, you were followed around.
Made sure you didn't harm yourself.
You were fed.
- [Kelly] You're doing all right
- Yeah.
- How did you do that with your-
- You know, we had read
that it was good to give
the older child a gift from the baby
when you came home with the baby.
We did it,
but my kid was like,
"Mmm, the baby got me a gift?"
(everyone laughs)
"Did the baby go and drive to get me a-
really, what money did the
baby buy this gift with?
This seems like a fabrication.
I'm not on board for it."
- [Kelly] It's lies.
- Exactly. Exactly.
- My kids, this is hilarious.
So they, they're six and eight
and they want me to have
another baby, right?
I'm like, like I don't
have enough going on.
And I, and I'm, I'm like,
I don't really think that's gonna happen,
but we can get a puppy.
And so I got a puppy.
But then their older sister
just had her first child and-
'cause she's quite a bit older-
and they went and they were so excited.
I was like, get your
baby stuff out right now
you're gonna go see
her, and her little one.
I was like, get it out.
My daughter was like, "Oh my God."
She's so excited.
And literally like four days later
she came back to me and was like,
"You're not allowed to have a baby."
- [Christina] Whoa.
- She was like, she was like,
"You can't, they just, they cry a lot."
The baby, I guess didn't attach to her
quite how she (giggles) wanted.
- Oh.
- So, she just, it was hilarious.
And I need to send a thank
you gift to her sister.
(everyone laughs)
'Cause I was like,
Mama's not having another baby right now.
So, okay.
So, we have to take
another commercial break
because I need to stop talking.
(audience laughs)
A new episode of Yellowjackets
premieres this Friday on Showtime
and Night Court airs on Tuesdays on NBC
and streams the next day on Peacock.